Hollywood is paying tribute to Penny
Marshall the pioneering movie director
and iconic star of Laverne and Shirley
Marshall who survived cancer died at
home Monday night of complications from
diabetes
she was 75 Henry Winkler said she was so
inventive so funny and so warm and Rosie
O'Donnell wrote I am absolutely
heartbroken we first got to know her on
the hit 1970s comedy with that
distinctive cursive L on her shoulder
Penny Marshall helped turn Laverne and
Shirley into a number-one hit she played
one half of Milwaukee's wackiest pair of
female brewery workers on the TV show
which also offered Marshall the first of
her many opportunities to sit in the
director's chair the 1988 movie big
starring Tom Hanks made Marshall the
first female director to break the
hundred million dollar mark at the box
office she did it again
four years later with a league of their
own which reunited her with Hanks and
featured a who's who of Hollywood's
leading ladies people forgotten what
life is all about her 1990 film
awakenings with Robin Williams and
Robert De Niro was only the second film
ever directed by a woman to be nominated
for a Best Picture Oscar Marshall sat
down at the CBS this morning table in
2012 but you talk very candidly about
how you were never happy with the way
that you look still not the Bronx native
often joked about succeeding in
Hollywood despite not having movie star
looks but it also loves your hair he or
she's playing foil to Farrah Fawcett in
an old shampoo commercial know what I
think you think you look adorable her
ex-husband the director Rob Reiner said
Marshall was blessed with a funny bone
which she used even when battling cancer
do you have a moment where you go why me
did you ever have that moment no I asked
the White Castle you would tragedy where
I deal with bad things very calmly when
I'm bored is when I'm in trouble
Marshall is survived by an older sister
a daughter and three grandchildren in a
statement her family said we hope her
life continues to inspire others to
spend time with family work hard and
make all of their dreams come true you
know she said I had a great life yeah
she really didn't people loved her so
she credited her brother for giving her
career I love Tom Hanks this morning
said goodbye penny man did we laugh a
lot
wish we still could love you Hank's
those two were very close and a true
pioneer both you and the camera and in
front of it all right I mean one of the
first female directors in so acclaimed
and for those of us who came home at the
end of the day and watched Laverne and
Shirley it's the fabric of our child
yeah yeah we need to all go get shirts
with our initials ng BJ I like that look